I've been asked a couple oppressions
about some other questions where there's
more than one being involved and also
there are fractions in the percentages
it's like what do I do with it okay so
if you've got your calculator there I'm
going to answer answer the second
question first gets a bit more
straightforward and then I'm actually
going to do one of the questions that
will show you what's going on with is
more than one year involved okay so if
you're going to calculator there just
get it out one of the questions I
believe it has the fracture or rather
has a percentage six and two thousand
percent how you guys done that question
Cena so when you're dealing with six and
two-thirds percent you sort of encounter
a bigger problem she's in your
calculator so I'm going to show you how
to do this properly to explain first
this as i was mentioning to a keel a
second ago if i gave you something like
this fine yes so this is like classic
either we've seen this hundred there's
no operation between 5 and X yeah so
what operation is implying it's
multiplication by we need five watts of
x 5 x it so therefore if you go to your
calculator and you type in something
like this six fraction two-thirds right
what you are and that's not for a couple
what your calculator is actually seeing
if or six and two-thirds as a mixed
numeral it's seeing this it seemed two
numbers next to each other so it thinks
you need six times two-thirds which is
not actually what we want okay so
therefore you're going to have to use on
top of this button if you go shift
fracture it hands you a mixer move right
away okay so i think what was it 300
liters or something like that is what
they're asking you that question so i
could do this in two steps like i did
earlier this is going to give me if i
hit equals on this right this is going
to give me the change this is going to
give me the increase in its going to
calculate it properly as a mix new rule
rather than
making this modification but of course I
can do it all in one step rather than
change and an advocate up how would I
change this light to give me the answer
in one hit 406 yeah so I want the six
and two-thirds percent and the one who
trips it at same time so what I'm going
to increase in there is put the 100 okay
so once you've done that this is that
formula we developed before you hit
equals and out pops your arms up okay so
just watch for that when you've got
weeks do Ross because this is gonna be
funny and that's why it's photo button
could you all how long your question 10
mins this is my question higher side so
I'm going to ask you to turn in our you
might not be up to it that's okay that's
kind of why I'm going to show you so
question turns on we'll look you
seven so it's just increased by time can
you raise your hand if you have
questions ham in view hands up straight
I'm still waiting for ya okay thank you
guys down so this question has lots of
parts and you need to have in front of
you so you can watch what's going on I
don't think all these peoples okay let's
have a look so you can see they're
giving you an amount of money that you
start off with oops I've lost the page I
think it's two thousand four hundred
dollars is that what they give you ok
and then year to year different things
happen to this amount of money so here's
the first question if in the first year
it increases by fifteen percent what do
you have at the end of that person okay
so commitment is not you can tell me
what working to put down right after the
first year right what do I get yep one
hundred and fifteen percent so there's
that original 100 and the 15 comes along
for the ride can someone give me a
number 2750 thank you ok so then what
happens is in the subsequent year
following this the same thing doesn't
happen like I don't know the share
market is doing better or less whatever
actually is it doing it's doing worse ok
so it's still increases but not as much
ok so when we look at Part B after the
second year I need the percentage of
eight percent eight percent increase ok
but importantly the second starts from
the end of the first year right so I'm
not going to say 2400 I'm gonna say two
thousand seven sixty that's my new start
point ok so I'm going to say to 760 x
108 percent good
there was no truth in the extra
percentage yes yeah it's very good so
that's my further paint % further to the
amount that i have the end of course
does that make sense so I think what
they mean by a you might give you a
further as in like are fifty percent and
a to the twenty-three percent but I
think what they mean is further the
entire first year was fifty percent and
in the second moves a I so I'm gonna go
by yeah yeah it's not about this can you
you know let me finish better than the
other necklace just someone happen over
2989 k excellent and this is dollars so
I'm gonna write it any better okay then
there were certain think about what
happens over the course of these hot
teen years and what others if I want to
go and reverse here's what I mean the
actual total change by the end of the 24
months total change is going to be where
you end it compared to a week so does
that make sense so this is my father
another here 2988 and what am I going to
subtract yeah right there at the
beginning right so i subtract that and
then this gives me about thank you